hey guys and welcome to episode 108
monkey [ __ ] [ __ ] okay that's actually
gonna prove their my point I got a call
again and I wasn't really able to make
many videos so that's why I've been kind
of dead again lately I always like
really confused and mad because it's
like the second call that I've had in a
couple of weeks and I normally don't
really care about that too much but it
just means that I can't record anything
buddy because I would be sniffing and
coughing all over the videos and I was
just not the most amazing thing but I
should be kind of back by now my voices
to orbitz it's not great but you know it
never is so I decided to just do this
episode anyway in this episode I'll be
making a building which is gonna really
resemble the tower also known as Big Ben
but which is actually not cold big bands
so i'll call it the Elizabeth Tower
because otherwise some English people
are probably going to throw some
crumpets at me because they're furious
that i miss name their tower but it's
also a bit of a Manchester kind of City
Hall ish tower in the sense that I kind
of wanted to draw influences from both
as the idea with this as well as many of
the other things that I'm trying to get
in as we nice because this is going to
be the major weenie for this area it's
going to have to be that thing that you
can see from the entire area that is
larger than the rest of the buildings to
give a real signature sort of building
of the area and I wanted to get
something that would really resemble
some very well-known monuments of
England but at the same time not be any
actual building in real life so that's
why I kind of want to make it a mix of
both buildings it has that really
stereotypical golden big banish clock on
it with of course the black spire like
that but I want to get some smaller
towers on the side in a similar vein to
how the city hof Manchester has that and
when it comes to the arches and the rest
of the building it's really just gonna
be a bit of a mash-up between both I
want to have a bit of Victorian ish
style to this building ridicula what the
Parliament building is known for but I
also want to get those of Gothic sort of
arches in that the City of Manchester
has
if you're not already very confused a
very briefly campus basically I'm going
to make a tower and trying to make it as
fancy as possible over here also this
thing is actually going to have a
function which is very rare for
buildings in this park so far i do want
to focus a lot more and actually getting
functionality because so far I do think
I've been building too many empty
buildings and for some areas it was
really important to get the ambience
especially for the amsterdam area but
over here I at least want to get some
sort of function to each part of this
area so the main part in front of this
is going to have planted some smaller
pavilions restaurants and even flat
rides and this building itself will be
the entrance facade to a dark right that
I am planning to have in this area so
that is pretty much that that being said
I don't know anything else about what I
really want to do with the dark ride
there's no real theme so far or what
sort of talk right I want to make I
suppose I'll just see that when I to it
and another point is that i will be
making that dog grind and recording it
on screen but i will not be making it in
this park site file most likely i'm
already having problems with the park
file and my current goal is to do half
of this park on this park file by my
estimate that and at around that time i
should be hitting about 15 Mbps on the
park file size which is just way too
much for all across the country to
handle I'll most likely get many crushes
and stuff but if I can reach getting
half of the park done by that time then
I can do the other half in a different
park file and I shouldn't have too many
problems trying to make this look like
one park while actually building it in
two different park files but it would be
a lot better than cutting it into three
parts for example because it is
obviously a lot easier to divide my park
into two parts just cut it in half and
just work in the other half in another
Park file so that's one thing another
thing that you may have noticed just on
the tower is that I actually pre built
this thing I just kind of messed up when
I was doing this I built it before just
to see if
I liked the way I would build it in game
to experiment with pieces that I could
use for it which would make sure that
this time lapse because if I didn't cut
that out this time I would have been 20
minutes of which 15 minutes would have
just been building that towers so I
tried to do it first not recording it
and then get into the actual park file
and build the tower in a much shorter
amount of time actually knowing what I
had to do but i dun goofed on nuts and I
actually don't remember everything so
that's why I sometimes got a structure a
prebuilt structure that looks very much
like this tower in there to kind of see
what sort of details I needed to do I
have not copied this building or
anything that was just a bit of
preparation that I actually kind of
[ __ ] up on normally I don't want to
show that in the time lapse but just
kind of happened today that being said
I'm rebuilding it just to get the time
lapse done and to actually also improve
a bit on the auto design add some extra
details and leave out some other things
that I don't like as much also you'll
probably see me scrolling around the
park quite a bit I was and I still am
very unsure about the height of this
building I really want to do a lot of
math study to see if the size of the
building is actually good so how it
looks from every angle of this section
of the park and currently the problem
that I have is that it just seems a bit
too low especially the towers seems to
be a bit too low but even the main
section of the building could be one or
two H higher and really the problem with
that is that you can't just make a
building one or two edged higher without
deleting the entire building or adding
some sort of weird fundament that it's
placed on that would be way too
awkwardly high so I think that at some
point I might actually completely
rebuilt the tower and make it higher
than it currently is but that's actually
something that I'll most likely do much
further into the future because the
planning is that around this building
I'll have many English buildings as well
I get a really nice englishtown facade
string going with all sorts of things
just standard English houses but also
get some Edwardian Victorian and of
course some though
still really have to look at how I want
to do that some to do houses as well one
of the problems that I'm running into
why I'm not really doing that yet is
because there is a lack of custom
scenery for it but as soon as I get that
problem solved I do want to go into that
and really the rest of this building was
just I almost feel like this is building
us amazing to look at when you look at
it from a distance but as soon as you
get closer to it is just yeah because
one of the main issues is that I
obviously didn't want or it could make a
heap load of custom seen read sets just
for this one building to get all the
nice details in so it's really just a
mishmash of every single custom seen
reset that I could find that could
somehow actually kind of fits what I
wanted to do so there's a lot of really
wet random stuff in there really when
dhum I shouldn't be making English jokes
no I should not be doing that um but
yeah that I don't know it's one thing
that always laxmi about that is when you
look up to it closely it's it looks fit
it looks but weird since for example I
use the like the top part of a wall for
castles as a sort of cornice piece to
divide the two floors and there are some
Ralphie's beaver home items in there as
well which makes the entire building
look fine and dandy when you look at it
from a distance but then as soon as you
come close it's like mmm aren't those
pieces supposed to be used for American
homes that's the sort of kind of feeling
that I'm getting with this building but
otherwise don't worry about it too much
I do like this building and the way that
it's shaping up right now and definitely
think it's gonna be a good very good
weenie for this area to do starts when
it comes to the details I might still
look at it later on but that's really
just a roller coaster in three traits if
you want to get some but if you want to
do a building style that requires many
details like a Victorian or pretty much
any very large building like a palace or
a church or anything like that it's
really just gonna have to be searching
for every single type of custom scenery
just to get those details and so and
that's just kind of what's happening
over here too so though I'm not really
worried about it it's something that I
would
rather not see but it's really
inevitable in this game if you want your
buildings to actually have that extra
bit of detail plus something that I also
want to be be aware of is the fact that
I don't want to over detail my buildings
because that's a clear thing details are
fine to add as long as you keep a
division between not so detailed
buildings and more detailed buildings
and if you keep a division between
detailed parts of buildings and not
detailed parts of buildings to give an
example this building has very detailed
and like it has pretty much sugar coated
walls but the roof itself of the
building itself is just gonna be simple
I'm holy [ __ ] i'm gonna breath there
it's just gonna be simple and really i'm
not going to add too much to that so
that kind of evens it out and doesn't
make the entire building just one big
sugar-coated pie of rear details in any
case that's it for this episode so thank
you for watching and I'll see you